well it is so good to be back on the
program to talk about such important
issues today as the popping of balloons
Alpha Joe Biden has popped the Chinese
balloon and trumpists are Furious why
are they Furious well it's not even
clear that they know
oh boy I I want to make clear that for
me this story is really about the meta
narrative in other words
there is a hilarious story here that has
developed and it is the story being told
about the story being told about this
Chinese surveillance balloon and so
we're not really talking about the
balloon per se
but we're talking about the narrative
about The Narrative of the balloon and
the story in reality is not really about
Joe Biden or Donald Trump but there is
something so funny about right Wingers
spending a couple of days saying weak
beta Joe Biden isn't going to do
anything about the balloon Biden orders
the balloon blown up and then we found
out that similar balloons maybe the same
balloon actually crossed over U.S
territory three times when Donald Trump
was president now that being said I'm
not going to
tell you anything we don't believe to be
true it seems right now that Trump was
not actually told about that now this is
the subject of some controversy and
we're going to talk about it but it
seems as though the latest claims are
the Trump Administration or Trump
specifically was not actually told about
this during his administration and so we
will get to that the Associated Press
has a worthwhile article if you want to
get caught up on this balloon bickering
over Biden's actions in China's
intentions the article reads Republican
lawmakers Sunday accused China of
deliberately surveilling sensitive U.S
military sites with a suspected spy
balloon and said the Biden
administration had given Beijing an
intelligence opening by not Downing the
balloon during its high altitude drift
during American airspace Now understand
that if you down the balloon while it is
over U.S land it's extraordinarily
dangerous and so there was a decision
made to wait until it was over water and
that is when the balloon was popped and
this is actually what we are talking
about here China meanwhile accused the
U.S of indiscriminate use of force when
the American Military shot it down the
vice foreign minister said he lodged a
formal complaint with the U.S embassy
very very aggressive they are not happy
about it
um then there is an article from the uh
from Business Insider Republicans are
blaming Biden for letting a suspected
Chinese spy balloon cross into the U.S
it happened three times during the Trump
Administration officials say would Trump
have let China fly a spy balloon over
our country tweeted Jim Jordan
Chinese spyballoons were cited three
times during the Trump Administration
now I tweeted yesterday
um that the story was there's a Chinese
balloon over U.S airspace Maga says
Biden won't blow it up Biden blows it up
Magus says big deal any president would
have blown it up and then we learned
actually it flew over U.S airspace three
times under Trump and Trump didn't blow
it up it is believed right now it is
believed right now that the Chinese spy
balloons that flew over U.S airspace in
U.S airspace under Trump were not
discovered until Trump was no longer in
office and if that's the case my tweet
yesterday was based on the information
we had then and we've since learned more
so you don't need to include that to
realize the absurdity of the story about
the story the story about the story is
Trump tough on China
Biden weak on China that's the that's
the the The Meta narrative that exists
here
in reality what we have is Biden
immediately went to military advisors
was told we can pop it but it could
actually hurt people if we did it while
it was over land so if you give the
order sir you can give the order for us
to pop it when it's not over land over
water took a couple of days for it to
reach that position and then it was
indeed popped Trump did not do anything
like that about these balloons our best
information now is that Trump didn't
have that opportunity and that's
perfectly fine but the story of Biden
very very weak on China
Trump very very strong on China
continues to fall apart and something
about this balloon story has massively
triggered Donald Trump let's see if we
can figure out what it is
over the weekend
failed former president Donald Trump
spent a ton of time on his social media
platform truth social essential truth
truth call it whatever you want one of
the topics which Trump addressed was
this spy balloon as it is being called
from China which was popped by Joe Biden
and Donald Trump sending a number of
outrageous truths let's just dig right
into them and see if we can figure out
why is the guy so triggered is it
because of his failing presidential
campaign is it because he wants
attention is it because it's a sort of
if I can't play in the sandbox I'm going
to poop in it so none of the other kids
can play it and either
I don't know Trump truth and quote the
Chinese balloon situation is a disgrace
just like the Afghanistan horror show
and everything else surrounding the
grossly incompetent Biden Administration
now what's funny about that is on on
Afghanistan when Trump was asked what
exactly would you have done differently
than Joe Biden he couldn't articulate
anything he would have done differently
Biden executed the Trump plan and
similarly just like Biden popped the
balloon Trump probably would have popped
the balloon so it's kind of kind of a
weird start Trump continues they are
only good at cheating in elections and
disinformation and now they are putting
out that a balloon was put up by China
during the Trump Administration in order
to take the heat off the slow-moving
Biden fools
China had too much respect for Trump for
this to have happened and it never did
just fake disinformation
well it turns out that that's not true
it turns out that there were Chinese spy
balloons which three times
flew over U.S airspace in U.S airspace
under Trump now in Trump's defense you
all know that there is plenty to slam
Trump about I don't need to make things
up in Trump's defense on this issue the
latest report as of a few hours ago is
that the Trump Administration was not
told about these balloons when they were
uh over in U.S airspace
um that this was learned about after
Biden took office so if that's the case
Trump's just going further Trump's
saying China never would have done it
well China did do it you just didn't
know about it Trump contribute
continuing on Troth Central quote who
sends a billion dollar blimp with the
most sophisticated equipment in the
world and large enough to hold 10 cars
or three large buses into a complex
pattern over the United States without
it quite possibly being manned such as
the manned spacecraft China should have
been called to ask if no shoot it down
if yes negotiate the greatest deal ever
I guess Trump is saying that he believes
that such a balloon likely would have
been manned even though there's no
evidence of that and if so he would have
tried I guess to kidnap the balloon and
its pilot which didn't exist and extort
the Chinese or something I mean this is
a very crazy way to manage Foreign
Relations but after all it is Trump and
then maybe the funniest truth of all
Trump then closing it out with quote the
Chinese would never have floated the
blimp quote balloon over the United
States if I were president and as I
already mentioned to you
Chinese spy balloons did fly in U.S
airspace three times while Donald Trump
was President of the United States as
far as we believe right now Trump wasn't
told about it but China did indeed have
the audacity often they play up well you
know Putin never would have invaded
because he was scared and China never
well China did
China did the thing he says they never
would have done now the third piece to
this Fiasco is what's the wildest
conspiracy theory to come out of it well
let's look at that next
Fox News hosts Trump brown noser and
vile propagandist conspiracy theorist
Maria Bartiromo has Unleashed maybe the
wackiest balloon conspiracy theory I
heard in the last 24 hours
Maria's suggestion is she's just asking
questions remember
did the balloon
okay let me even back it up did China
send the balloon so that it would be
popped by Biden so that then it would
disperse surveillance products that are
solar powered to now allow unlimited
surveillance I read a science fiction
book with technology like this let's
listen to what Maria Bartiromo says Miss
China did it drop and disperse
surveillance products powered by solar
energy to allow unlimited surveillance
and why did it take U.S officials so
long to shoot it down was it a test for
the CCP to see if it can send something
into America's airspace undetected right
and how much surveillance is communist
China performing on America right now
right so of course China is performing
surveillance on the U.S the U.S is
performing surveillance over China U.S
is performing surveillance over Russia
and Russia over the U.S this is sort of
the way things work but this is a wacky
wacky conspiracy theory and it's funny
on a couple levels first of all
these right Wingers are constantly
talking about how unreliable solar
energy is you know when it's cloudy it
doesn't work did you know that when
there's no sun when it's night time you
don't get any solar energy okay all of a
sudden the very technology they claim is
worthless and shouldn't really be a part
of American Energy Mix they are saying
it's being used in the most
sophisticated way we can imagine
which is that the balloon was filled
with solar-powered surveillance Elements
which have now been dispersed across the
United States because the balloon was
popped by stupid Joe Biden fine first it
was Biden won't pop the balloon now it's
Biden popped it but is that exactly what
China wanted Biden to do the other funny
thing about it is the military under
Biden's orders waited until the balloon
was over water to pop it so that it
wouldn't present a risk to people and so
whatever was just released I guess is
now doing surveillance on the bottom of
the ocean or whatever the case may be
um I actually wonder if the balloon is
what made that massive dump of ballots
on Election night we should really look
into that one other funny clip here
related to this a Republican senator
Marco Rubio
was interviewed by uh ABC's Jonathan
Carl and Rubio showed up and he says you
know what China the message China was
sending was you guys you the United
States under Biden you're not going to
do anything about this balloon and then
Jonathan Carl points out well it was
actually shot out of the sky and Rubio's
like yeah but and then he inserts a
wacky word salad get over the sky and
the message they were trying to send is
what they believe internally and that is
that the United States is a once great
superpower that's hollowed out that's in
Decline and the message they're trying
to send the world is look these guys
can't even do anything about a balloon
flying over U.S airspace how can you
possibly count on them if if something
were to happen in the indo-pacific
region you're going to count how can you
count on them if they're not going to do
anything about a balloon over U.S
airspace right except they did how are
they going to come to the aid of Taiwan
or stand with the Philippines or Japan
or India if when the Chinese move on
their territory so I think that that's
really the the key part here is they
they knew exactly what they were doing
and um and there was a message behind it
but the balloon was shot out of the sky
what do you mean I mean the balloon was
taken down
yeah and I think they understood that
ultimately that would probably be what
would could happen and then they would
make this other statement about all the
US is overreacting it's just a weather
balloon look how silly they got that's
part of it as well but what they know
the world is going to see is you have a
balloon that entered through the Alaska
traversed everywhere from Idaho and
Montana across the Midwest over some of
the most sensitive I mean look at the
flight path that this thing took it's
not coincidental it went over right so
first the problem is listen they do this
and they know we're not going to do a
damn thing about it well but we did we
shot it out of the sky right but look at
the flight path that it took and anyway
they had a response queued up these
people will say anything they will be
confronted with the facts and then they
will just spit out another word salad
it's conspiracies and meaningless
rhetoric all the way down is there a
real story here about surveillance of
course there is of course there is is
the story being taken seriously by
people like Marco Rubio and Maria
Bartiromo you know the answer of course
the answer is no
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
with total peace love and respect I ask
you if you'd like to support the work
that we are doing get yourself a
membership at joinpakman.com we have an
entire extra show that we do every day
for our members it's called the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money yeah everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
quite simply yes Alex that is what it is
it is an extra show every day and it is
part of how we fund what we do we also
offer a commercial free audio and video
stream of the show every day hours
before the show is published for
everybody else we also have members only
town halls and we now have the David
packman show sound board thank your
lucky stars every day you're not Dave
Pacman we have the sound board available
to you in the membership control panel
all of those things and more at
joinpakman.com is anti-globalism just
anti-semite autism a viewer named Jesse
wrote to me about this and I think it's
a good opportunity to talk about whether
this entire Obsession that the right has
with how global-ish are bad global-ished
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike Obama Trudeau macron okay yeah
you get it whenever a right-winger or a
reactionary talks about the globalist
system and the globalists and all of it
they are often actually referring to the
idea of a Jewish conspiracy to control
this that or the other thing now they
use code words to mask their intentions
and many of the people touting this
anti-globalist stuff don't even realize
that it is a thinly veiled anti-semitic
conspiracy many of them are just
regurgitating talking points that they
heard from somebody else without even
really understanding the origins or the
oranges of so-called anti-globalism
globalism exists in the in what I mean
is the idea of globalism as something
separate from Jews are doing stuff does
exist globalism is the operation and
planning of Economic and foreign policy
on a global basis right that would be
when rather than as individual countries
you have global economic planning you
have Global foreign policy planning
that's a real thing in terms of it could
be something that exists most of these
right Wingers
that talk about globalism don't actually
give a damn about real globalism as I
just described it to you for many of
them it's just another way to spread
their hateful ideology to place a Target
on particular people and it is often a
thinly veiled placeholder for
anti-semitic conspiracy theories it's
actually similar to I this is so fraught
to ever mention George Orwell's 1984
because it's so often mentioned in ways
that has actually nothing to do or have
nothing to do with what George Orwell
wrote about but when you think back to
Orwell's 1984
and you think about Goldstein as
a tool to fuel hatred towards Jews a
bogeyman or a boogeyman depending on
your preference
anti-globalism has become a similar
coded dog whistle version of
anti-Semitism and so it's a way that
right Wingers can spread their hate and
their intolerance under a more
politically correct veneer they claim to
be against political correctness they
want to just say things as they are say
things as they are for them would be to
be going after Jews but I guess they
realize they have to be a little more
politically correct maybe I don't know
and so they're calling it we're against
globalism rather than we just have these
conspiracy theories about Jews we have
seen this kind of talk before
and I know many of you know exactly
where we have to go back to and it's the
1930s and we saw where it led then
disastrous consequences for marginalized
communities including Jews and others as
well so what we really should do as we I
mean it's like okay David great many of
us suspected that anti-globalism is
really just coded anti-Semitism but what
can we actually do about it well one
thing you can do is call it out for what
it is
anti-globalism isn't this harmless
political Viewpoint it's a form of
anti-Semitism with the potential to lead
to terrible things and one idea just one
idea for how to handle it is when you
hear these folks start talking about
globalism how globalism is bad ask them
to explain exactly which policies and
initiatives they're opposed to it's very
easy for them to say well I'm against
all of the ideology of George Soros and
Klaus Schwab for example
but that's not policy ask them for
policy now some may say well I'm against
dealing with climate in a global way
like for example with the Paris climate
Accords okay we could talk about Paris
climate but most of them won't actually
have any examples of the globalism they
claim to be against and what's what's
interesting is and kind of funny and sad
for people spending so much time talking
about globalism you would think they'd
be able to list at least a bunch at
least a few
globalist policies but in my experience
I would be shocked if they can actually
name a single one maybe they'll mention
Paris climate uh but of course countries
can just opt out as Trump did opt out
the United States during his presidency
so yes anti-globalism a very flimsy
veneer
for anti-Semitism
Democrats have made a massive dump of
Iowa as the first vote in the 2024
primary I think this is very interesting
and quite frankly I'm in favor of it and
I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about why Reuters has a good explainer
very very straightforward what's going
on Democrats approve Biden's revamped
primary calendar the DNC on Saturday
approved a shake-up of the 2024 primary
calendar giving black voters a greater
say in the nominating process and
carving an easier path for Biden's
expected re-election bid
the party's vote Saturday replaces the
famed Iowa caucuses as the first in the
nation with South Carolina a state with
significantly more black voters and one
that saved Biden's 2020 presidential
campaign it would be followed by New
Hampshire and Nevada one week later than
by Georgia and Michigan now we've talked
about this for a while now the this is
happening at what is arguably a
politically fraught time because I've
been saying we need to do something like
this for multiple election Cycles why is
Iowa first Iowa is is 90 percent white
it's extraordinarily rural it's not
representative of anything about the
Democratic party or voters in general or
preferences for candidates it just gets
a lot of attention because it's first
and why is it first it's not really
clear that it should be so for a very
long time I've been saying South
Carolina is not a bad choice racially
South Carolina is very much more aligned
with a national demographics you know
Iowa's 90 white South Carolina is 69
percent white that is much closer to the
U.S population you could look at other
demographics you could say well how what
about education what about age what
about you can always pick and say this
state is more representative in this way
but that state is more representative
okay we could do that
one thing is for sure
Iowa is neither representative nor
should it be first every time around so
we've floated different ideas over time
what about a different order every
election cycle it could be randomized so
one year it's one state that goes first
one year it's another or picking
particular States I think South Carolina
is a fine state to go first I think
moving on to New Hampshire Nevada
Georgia Michigan these are certainly
more representative States in many ways
than Iowa the reason this is now
becoming particularly contentious is
that you might remember that in 2020
South Carolina saved Joe Biden Joe Biden
was not doing particularly well in those
early primaries now you could say well
he wasn't doing well but those were
early primaries not representative of
the national Democratic electorate
that'd be one perspective so you could
say it made sense that when you got to a
more representative State like South
Carolina
Biden did well and then he went on to
win the Counterpoint to that is that the
South Carolina situation was very much
stage managed to deny Bernie the
nomination
um and to uh get Joe Biden
um uh the electoral votes that uh he he
very not the uh delegate votes delegate
numbers that he needed and you might
remember that uh James Clyburn came out
and uh endorsed and strongly supported
Joe Biden followed by a number of other
candidates including Pete boot Edge who
dropped out at a time that was very
convenient for Joe Biden so although
this would make sense any year this
particular election cycle it really does
seem pointed at helping Joe Biden who
has not yet announced his re-election
campaign but is indeed expected to let
me know your thoughts does this make
sense because it makes sense does it
make less sense because it specifically
is likely to help Biden what do you
think make sure that you weigh in which
you can do on our Instagram by finding
us at davidpackman show or of course on
the YouTube channel which exploded after
I came to you with tears in my eyes for
help at the end of January added almost
000 new YouTube subscribers in January
make sure you are one of the 1.6 closing
in on 1.7 million we'll take a quick
break and be right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show our
correspondent and occasional guest host
Luke Beasley whose Channel you can find
at davidpackman.com Luke went to Donald
Trump's South Carolina event this was
that extraordinarily low energy event
that Jesse dolomore covered for us last
week now this is a completely whacked
group of people that went to this event
and I'm gonna play some clips of Luke
speaking to them in a moment but one of
the things that many of you have emailed
me about is David I'm where great about
Luke many of you said it is is he is he
safe at these events and at this event
for the first time that I'm aware of
people started shouting insults and
threats to Luke as it became clear that
he was asking completely respectful but
certainly adversarial questions as he
conducted his interviews we're going to
get to that and we've got to talk about
Luke's safety in a bit we're going to
first start with we will call him guy
number one let's just get right into it
I present these without any introduction
uh this is pretty wacky stuff buckle up
I know what the truth is and I believe
everything that happened in January 6th
is going to be revealed every bit of it
and now we know what happened on January
6th I don't know exactly what you're
referring to so what would you say that
is what occurred on January 6th talking
about Nancy Pelosi which she instigated
and the information she's got will be
found on her laptop
and that will be eventually it will be
revealed to the American people it's not
just Hunter's laptop now it's Nazi
Pelosi's as he says
so Nancy Pelosi instigated January 6.
she did what would be the purpose of
them coordinating this great question
what's the end game there the end game
is to get Trump out so he doesn't win
the presidency of course Trump is out uh
the 2020 election I believe was stolen I
think majority of the people here
believe that 2022 was stolen they did it
again so let me pause this to you
um if their goal was to get Trump out of
office and the certification was what
was going on during January 6 meaning
they were doing the process to get Trump
out of office right certifying Biden's
win then
causing January 6 would be the opposite
of what they would want because it
absolutely perfect question why would
they interrupt the process to remove
Trump if what they want to do is remove
Trump interfere with the certification
right I didn't get that last part the
actions of January 6 actually interfered
with the certification so doesn't it
kind of not make sense that the
Democrats would have instigated January
6 if that got in the way of the
certification which they wanted because
that was going to cause Biden to become
president
sure
I just believe
that
I am not artificially extending the
silence folks just so you know
I don't know he doesn't know he doesn't
know presented with a simple question he
doesn't know still speaking to guy
number one here Trump is really in
control he says but if bad things happen
those aren't Trump's fault what and I
believe God is in charge of the whole
thing he's got everybody in the place
that he wants about
if you put Trump in there in 2016.
and I actually believe that Trump is
President right now whoa really I do and
he's in
in control to to the military is this
mental illness
the military has more more power over
the federal government and state
government military law
um
how would you describe kind of I know
what happened they know what happened
during the election I believe they have
proof of it okay and that will be
revealed and right now how would you
describe the state of America
it's not good this is a brilliant set of
questions by Luke by the way he's really
getting good at this it's not good
as Trump's in control would you blame
him for that
no no why not
well because I think things are getting
better
think of that folks Trump's really in
charge right now oh and how are things
going terribly so since Trump's in
charge is that his fault no why not
because things are getting better
absolutely brilliant absolutely
brilliant we then go to lady number one
let's see what she had to say to Luke
here besides Trump what do you want to
hear from him
I've heard everything I've wanted from
him
I want him to take down all the people
who are in place right now right
so this is super simple question but
somehow I do get different uh answers to
it who's the president right now
I'm will tell okay she can't tell you
who is president but time will tell us
it will come Out Come On We're Not Gonna
Know I Know Okay God knows and the woman
knows who is president but we're not
gonna know that's very very interesting
now then we go to guy number two guy
number two proposes a different idea
altogether about what took place on
January 6th so you brought up uh January
6 in the con within the context of Nancy
Pelosi her son what do you think because
I've heard a number of different takes
on this
if not the official narrative that we
all saw meaning Trump supporters angry
about the statements troubles making
attacking the capital what do you think
happened what was Nancy Pelosi
coordinating or something right well
I've definitely investigated the
situation I was there
were buses that came in and all one has
to do is take pictures of those tags on
those buses
go to those bus companies and track who
paid for them you were there where I
drinks there
yeah in the capital I was not on the
lawn the day before when Enrique a
member of The Proud boys was busted in
the airport with he's talking about
Enrique atario plastic magazines that
they retailed to try to make money for
their cause
I knew that the mayor and something was
going on
so take a quick class the FBI hasn't
knocked on my door yet
I was smart enough to turn around and
get back yeah he wasn't going to be
picked up as a patsy that's for sure so
we're sticking with this guy and he also
seems to stumble upon this idea that
someone else is in charge he believes
it's Barack Obama I believe the military
is in charge right now
oh this is what I've heard before so if
the military is in control do you mean
they're running everything Biden isn't
we know Biden's not
um Biden's definitely not running
anything I believe uh President Obama is
actually calling shots right now and
everything that I've researched is
pointing toward that do you understand
the amount of research this man has done
and all of it points to Obama is in
charge what
who's who's going to sit back and watch
all this happen Mike Lindell proved
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt that enough
cheating went on in that election that
it would have changed the outcome yeah
obviously many would say he didn't but
to move on from that speaking of like
obviously the facts don't point to that
at all Glendale
um he's predicted multiple times that by
this date Trump will take back over as
president the military will bring him in
does it not make you go oh wait maybe
the claims he's been making about other
things are also lies because he lied
about this or at least falsely predicted
something about this I don't believe
Mike lindell's got a bad bone in his
body he is a true Christian I ministered
for years this guy also not only did he
research and found that it's Obama who's
in charge he also was a minister and
knows that Mike Lindell is really an
amazing Christian okay now we go to guy
number three here was we start with who
is the president
um and sounds like a simple question but
I get different answers to it who's the
president right now
definitely not Joe Biden
interesting and who is then yeah the
words it's a I want to say it's uh we're
being
it's a movie
if you think about it
gonna need elaboration on that yeah
who's President not Biden who is
president well it's a movie
there's way too much things going on
behind the scenes to even look at what's
going on the mainstream TVs you
understand you can get that
all right and then I would be like no I
don't get that dude diving into that
what's going on behind the scenes
it's it's hard to even fathom what end
of the uh this guy clearly he knows
we're not getting the truth but he
doesn't know what the truth is
it's a good way to put that word for you
the amount of pedophilia that's in this
system is insane it's just jammed up are
you kind of just hearing that makes you
think of you know where I'm going you
and I do yeah no I understand accusing
and there's a lot of speculation there
but yeah but I'll follow it to you and
uh it may not Shock you guys this is a q
Anon do your own research I just don't
hear speculation the funny thing about
do your own research is these people all
claim to be doing their own research and
they come away with crazy ideas like for
example uh you know Trump's president or
Obama's president or Nancy Pelosi's
laptop holds the key or whatever
whatever research they're doing doesn't
seem to be getting them any closer to
sanity you can pull up your own
information and it's Crystal Clear do
you know Mike Lindell yeah
and do you like the man of death but I'm
so sick of seeing his commercials all
right okay so one of the things he's
a good example to me of this phenomenon
that I see a lot in what would be called
conspiracy theory circles is making a
bold prediction Trump's going to become
president by this period of time it
doesn't happen and then I get confused
because the followers don't stop
trusting him Mike Lindell is predicted
just around the corner Trump's going to
be by this August whatever then that
hasn't happened or I agree and why
doesn't that cause you not to support
them and think oh maybe what they're
selling me is
dishonest great question
um things have they have channels they
have to go through and things have to
happen in certain
way to happen
even if it takes 50 years so
all right I'm sorry I'm on the spot I
got you um all right so anyway this guy
loses his train of thought and it only
goes downhill from there then we get to
guy number four and hear the threats
start from off camera good criticism of
any system throughout this country is
necessary I don't think suppressing uh
any type of criticism wrong or right uh
is is I'm gonna get to you next just try
not to be too loud so now this there's
someone hurling hurling uh abuse at Luke
and then it gets worse
oh God this is exactly the stuff we were
all worried about right and so this is
something we're going to have to talk
about because this gets much worse and
as you can see people looking around now
looking over what's going on here
um okay
that's it Oh I thought you're talking
about with our election processes
with our
you gotta come interview if you're gonna
be making all that noise
now other people start coming over
saying well dude you got to calm down
and I understand
Luke's doing a really good job here but
this is what when you're trying to focus
in and do an interview and there's
someone so close screaming stuff this
loudly at you
it is not comfortable see this is the
problem
[Music]
hey guys that's right it's all right
it's right that's right now in in the
defense of some of these folks they're
some of these Trump people are actually
telling this guy hey you got to lay off
that's right listen we're all Americans
here and we love like see this is the
problem this is the problem I wish like
people like you and me could sit and
have these discussions that's why I'm
here 100 like so if you're still taking
someone else's word for it you're still
believing into someone saying hey hey
trust me
and this is the biggest see this is the
biggest problem now we need to have
discussions like this but there's always
going to be like a subset of the
population that's going to
yeah I'm with you yeah so Luke uh visit
visibly flustered there
um we then speak to a guy who believes
that there's demonic oppression and
Trump is really president the guy's also
wearing a star of David uh again just to
just uh
um remember folks most American Jews are
very liberal most American Jews do not
believe in demonic possession most
American Jews do not believe Trump is
really the president all right uh what
brought you here what are you hoping to
see and hear I'm hoping to see the
president of the United States Donald
Trump and I came here because this
country is in such bondage in such
demonic oppression we are heading
towards commune it's in bondage and it's
been afflicted by Sato masochism as well
we need people to be praying for this
hold on I talked just go back a second
Russian we are heading towards communism
we need people to be praying for this
country to be praying for the president
Donald Trump
and to pray for people's eyes to be
opened so the truth of where our
country's heading because communism is a
very real thing it's it's real there is
no communism in the United States
Marxism is very very real thing we have
Marxist running our country who
we have
babies being killed after they're born
no we have all of these are trying to
take away our first amendment no trying
to take away our Second Amendment no
they're trying to destroy our
constitution let's do it one bit at a
time so you start off by saying
president United States is that kind of
because we love them or because you
genuinely believe he's still the
president both
okay
um then speaking to a guy with a let's
go Brandon fjb sweater and check out the
word salad this guy delivers when Luke
asks about the classified documents
double standard uh what's your response
to the Biden classified documents
Scandal yeah it's just hypocritical man
the way they responded to trumps and
then not so much Scandal to his on the
media just really shows the power
between the two parties but I think this
does play a lot better into Trump's
favor because they've really quieted
down more on his media side ever since
that happened yeah so I have heard a lot
of the complaints from the right kind of
being double standard the doj's too
aggressive a trump they rate him but one
of you agree there's very different
facts of situation Trump withholding the
documents worth biting gave them up
immediately
yeah it's just really just honestly a
personal standpoint at that point it
kind of shows this is where it goes off
the rails what is this guy talking about
a person that Trump is versus the kind
of person that Biden is to where Trump's
gonna stand for his word and what he
believes is what's going to be his way
while bite is just going to play towards
the system which he's basically bought
into and just kind of leaning towards
that side of it but if it would be
illegal to have those documents that is
it a positive to stick to his his
principles at that point you're already
guilty for what you're having like I'm
not gonna keep on it but yeah at that
point I was like in incredible I mean so
sometimes it I really do get the
impression the people who are sometimes
weighing in on this stuff have never
actually thought through their opinion
until the microphones in front of their
face and they would be much better off
just saying hey you know what I haven't
really thought about that let me I
should think about that before I give
you an opinion but they the mic is there
and the camera turns on and they'll
weigh in on whatever
um really good job by Luke you can find
Luke Beasley's channel uh go to
davidpackman.com Luke and we are going
to have to have a conversation about
Luke's safety at these events because
this would this one started to get quite
ugly and uh it's something we're going
to talk about all right all of these
clips find them on our YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show we
will have these on tick tocks and Tick
Tock we will have them on Instagram
Facebook everywhere excellent job by
Luke we'll take a quick break and be
right back
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
well it has been a very tough first four
weeks for endlessly lying Republican
Congressman George Anthony kitara
devolder Santos uh not only has he been
caught in numerous additional lies since
taking office he has already been
accused of sexual harassment or sexual
harassment if some some of our
1990s politics followers May uh may
remember it being pronounced
um let's take a look at what the
allegations are the New York Times
reports George Santos accused of sexual
harassment and Capitol Hill office
the complaint was made by a man seeking
work as a house aide whose bid for a job
was rejected because he faced criminal
wiretapping charges in Ohio
the man Derek Myers briefly worked for
Santos's office before the offer was
rescinded earlier this week according to
the letter Meyer said in the letter he
was alone with Santos on in his office
on January 25 when the congressman asked
him whether he had a profile on Grindr a
popular gay dating app then he said Mr
Santos invited him to karaoke and
touched his groin assuring him that his
husband was out of town Mr Meyer's
account could not be corroborated but a
spokeswoman for representative Susan
Wilde acknowledged that this that his
letter had been received by her office
Meyer said in an interview he did file a
report with the Capitol Police speaking
to an officer over the phone
on Twitter he said he was making his
complaint public for the sake of
transparency
they are serious offenses and evidence
and facts will speak for themselves if
the committee takes up the matter
um so
one of the things that I think is
important here
is we don't want in our criticisms of
George Santos to fall into homophobic
tropes and so as an example George
Santos lied about many things he lied
about uh his ethnicity
he lied about his work history he lied
about his educational history he lied
about his
um history and Athletics he lied about
his medical history he appears to have
lied about the death of his mother
claiming that she died at at least twice
and on and on and on and also we have
this thing where even though he says he
was hoping openly gay he was married to
a woman and these different things I've
stayed away from the married to a woman
thing because I'm aware that in society
because of stigma and shame that is
launched at LGBT folks in many instances
there is a long history of gay men who
also were married at some point to women
and so I've kind of stayed away from
that because there's so much other stuff
that we can criticize him for even if I
mean like you know there's this conflict
where he said he was he was openly gay
but I we don't even really need to get
into that and I don't want to get in
anywhere near any of these homophobic
tropes on the sexual harassment thing
there are Republicans who are very
quickly saying this is the problem with
gay men
that this is has nothing to do with him
being gay he is gay so the guy he
allegedly sexually harassed happens to
be a man but we have seen most elements
of sexual harassment by members of the
House and Senate that they are
heterosexual and so I want to be careful
in our coverage of this to stay away
from anything approximating that
homophobic Trope we've talked about the
homo homophobic Trope about gay men as
pedophiles and the homophobic Trope
about gay men as sexual harassers and we
want to be clear in our coverage that
that is not our story now that all being
said
I do think it's important to remember
for example when former Democratic
senator Al Franken resigned after just
the accusation of sexual misconduct
which turned out to be a tasteless joke
that took place years before Franken was
even in elected office he took a
tasteless tasteless picture where he
pretended he was going to touch a
sleeping woman and in their effort I
guess to show how not like Republicans
they are even many Democrats demanded
Franken resign and he did and uh we want
to be conscious of the differences in a
lot of these different circumstances
they are not all the same Santos is very
quickly becoming the prototypical
Republican uh that is for sure and
there's also the element of how stupid
is this guy and what I mean by that is
got caught lying about everything under
multiple investigations and on January
5th as the audacity to allegedly do
something like this in his own office
and yes Democrats would have removed the
sky a long time ago Democrats aren't
perfect I don't care about the
Democratic party in any particular way
but on this issue there is no chance in
hell that if Santos were a Democrat and
got caught doing the things he's he's
got caught doing uh there's no chance he
is still in office and that is
abundantly clear my friends let's talk
about woke especially and specifically
the perversion of the term woke to the
point where the anti-wokists don't even
know what they're talking about and what
they mean when they talk about woke
before it was perverted by the American
right wing the term woke simply meant I
have become aware of the causes of
social justice through activism pretty
benign the idea was challenge the status
quo fight against systematic and
systemic oppression to try to create a
better world
pretty benign that is not what the term
means anymore and in fact I don't even
know that anyone on the left is even
still using the term in anything other
than satirical fashion and this is
because over time the term woke has been
completely hijacked its meaning has
become vague ambiguous and has been
almost erased completely
because right Wingers have turned the
term woke into a pejorative they use it
to demonize they use it to dismiss
people advocating for social justice if
you identify an injustice the right will
dismiss your concerns by saying you were
just a wokster or go back to wokeestan
or whatever the case may be but the very
right-winger is doing that don't even
really know what the term means
understand that right-wing pundits are
masters of playing the victim of
demonizing the opposition of engaging in
binary thinking everything is either
this or that there are no gray areas in
the world and they are incredibly
effective at convincing viewers to align
with their ideology by using these dog
whistles by using these emotional
appeals and using fear and anger we've
talked about that before as well to
trigger an immediate response
the problem is many people don't even
understand what they're angry about and
that very much applies to wokeness
they're against wokeness because of CRT
and cat litter and black lives matter or
something but they've never actually
taken a moment to learn are the cat
litter stories true no they're not
is there anything about critical race
theory that is valuable or that I might
agree with in some way not that doesn't
matter they've never taken the time to
understand actually understand what are
the Grievances of the black lives matter
movement and even if I disagree with
execution for example
um or like for example me I have
concerns about the way in which
anti-Semitism has pervaded black lives
matter I can still understand
the causes and the worthiness of many of
those no no no no no no they don't even
really know what it means to be trans
but they're programmed to believe that
it's so it's wrong and it's woke and
these groups have all become so powerful
and they're indoctrinating people and
they're indoctrinating children and this
is how and why the term woke
has become completely perverted it is no
longer
of course it is no longer a message to
describe or a term to describe activism
social justice but it has actually
become a tool for the right to
reflexively throw out without
understanding it to stop conversation
Remember When the Right used to love to
say to some on the left being offended
isn't an argument right you would have
these conversations where for example
during the era of uh of the gay marriage
debate such as it was you would have
this period where people on the right
would go I just believe marriage is
between a man and a woman and someone on
the left would go I find that offensive
and the person on the right would go
being offended isn't an argument and I
agreed with them being offense being
offended isn't an argument
they are now doing the exact same thing
when they go that's woke crap we don't
want woke crap they are not making an
argument they are not addressing the
merits or the facts or the substance of
any particular position or issue they
are using a term that much like I'm
offended just serves to shut down the
conversation dismiss people's concerns
and disqualify uh their participation in
those discussions so understand the term
itself has been perverted and we need to
be aware of the way in which the right
achieve that we have a voicemail number
that number is 2192 David P I will have
more to say about my appearances in uh
Florida last week including on the
Patrick bat David show but here is one
voicemail about the pbd podcast
appearance
David I just saw your interview with
Patrick Bet David yes and you nailed it
thank you knocked him out of the park he
did not know his talking points you did
amazing I hope you will continue to do
these kind of interviews including on
Rogan
uh
I'm not sure which other ones you would
do but this guy who seems to think he
knows what he's talking about right and
he's confronted by facts and he's
knocked down
and you do it in a respectful way I
think those are the kind of interviews
you need to keep doing and I hope you
keep doing them love the show peace out
well listen I received both positive and
negative comments about the pbd
appearance I actually do think I could
have been better prepared in some areas
I didn't know what he was going to talk
to me about but there were areas where I
felt I could have been better prepared I
think it went okay you know the thing
about doing a lot of these especially
the ones that are in person is it's a
ton of work and last week I was I was on
vacation anyway so it sort of worked out
but often in order to do a single
podcast appearance I have to miss
usually it's like two days of the show
we need guest hosts all of this stuff
costs money Logistics Etc so it's it's
really a logistical limitation and they
are more compelling when I'm in person
than than via Skype like I understand
that so I'm hoping to do more The Lex
Friedman thing got canceled Lex canceled
that I don't know that Rogan's
interested in ever having me on again
but
we're going to try to keep doing a mix
of stuff and we will be publishing the
pbd podcast with my comments very soon
and I appreciate everybody's thoughts on
uh on on how it went we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today Ted Cruz wants
a two-term limit for senators but he
wants a third term remember the rules
don't apply to him right uh we will talk
about a ban on marijuana users owning
guns being found unconstitutional by the
ruling of a judge and we will talk about
limiting sugar in school meals for the
first time how has this not happened
before all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show use your machine to
sign up at joinpakman.com we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines yes sign up before pillow takes
your machine and you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get a discount
it's great to be back I will see you on
the bonus show or otherwise tomorrow